heart disease by far that's the thing
that kills most people then respiratory
disease fortunately now fewer people are
smoking
um and we're beginning to see the tail
off of diseases associated with
cigarette smoking but what vaping is
going to do we still don't know remember
it took us 30 40 50 years to work out
that cigarette smoking was as dangerous
so vaping at the minute okay said to be
fine but we'll see in years to come
whether there are any long-term diseases
if we're thinking about accidental
deaths probably drugs with or without
road traffic accidents if we're thinking
about murders
it's stabbings stabbing stabbing
stabbings they are the commonest cause
of death and the person most likely to
stab you is a friend or a relative